[Music]
Beyonce and jay-z honored at the 30th
annual day and Jay were there to accept
the Vanguard Award which is presented to
LGBTQ allies who have made significant
strides in supporting the community we
are highlighting the achievements of
this year honoring some amazing allies
fiance JC have you heard of them up and
comers GLAAD considers Queen B and Hova
to be global icons and passionate
defenders of human rights who promote
acceptance for all people
during the Beyonce tribute and I witness
tells et RuPaul's Drag Race star
shangela got down and brought the singer
to her feet
[Applause]
although the power couple skipped the
red carpet stars who did walk had
nothing but praise for the pair I've
already got a game plan and half and get
close now I'm not gonna get that close
because I saw security I'll take you
down his name is Julius to Beyonce and
jay-z but I'm you know what it's amazing
for me to be in the room this night my
first drag number that I ever did was
Beyonce single ladies in 2009 and fast
forward 10 years and Here I am in a room
where she's gonna be honored and I'm
also costing the live auction tonight
and you know it's just phenomenal
honey I'm putting a ring on it you on
top of the world let's do one of these
we're bracing ourselves jvn to be in the
presence of queen bee or your middle KZ
I met her once and I met JC once at a
basketball game and he shook my hand and
it was like the softest most buttery
lotion Hannah Doerr fell and I was like
I'm never gonna watch this what do you
smell like power money
[Music]